are we supposed to we were supposed to
go to a Halloween Horror Nights oh I
would not scary for him can I give you
my review yeah
not scary for him but for to celebrate
my 10th year of sobriety it was amazing
but one thing the actors there's actors
that scare you within they they're a
little bit too much
what do you mean like extra oh my they
get this close yeah I mean there's a
clown area where there's just okay so
there's actors within the mazes there's
ten different mazes or nine different
mazes and they all have their own themes
the first one was the depths or whatever
there's different themes
there's actors in there but then there's
also actors that walk around the
amusement park to scare you and there's
different themes within the park but
there's one section where there's all
clowns like there's a clown that was
wearing like stilts and there's and then
but the clowns had metal some kind of
metal thing blade thing where they would
skid like I saw it like there's a group
of Hispanic girls like high school kids
and this guy this clown was hiding and
he literally out of the bushes came
across and skid with that metal chute
and it made sparks but it almost like
cut her damn foot okay and she was like
she was so startled she was crying do
you know what I'm like dude but
something happened with me in like the
second maze what happened what was the
theme take your time take your watch
build the world world what theme yeah
where are we I don't know what the
second it was called it was there was a
alien theme is the first one it was
called the depths and it was the
underwater ocean theme where there's
ocean creatures but the second one was
it was called dark entities it was a
lien monster theme hmm so it was you
know they're scaring you within the the
maze but towards the end of the maze
this one guy he went he got too close to
me you know and I palm struck them oh my
god so I did a Bruce Lee like palms out
of it but I hit him like right here well
we uh you know
yeah then he goes you broke character
people character yeah he broke character
he goes you hit me man he goes yo
there's cameras in your mother foot you
know and a like you know actor what I
don't know I mean I was just protecting
I think it was just interesting yeah and
then when Howard did then that that's it
it was I Lani with you yeah what did she
say
so I was there with I Lani omni boy rain
our neighbor and our neighbor da you
know what that would have been nice to
get an invite wouldn't have been nice to
do a nice is the same but we had a deal
with you our neighbors were going and we
picked up yeah it was just at the I
wouldn't probably gone yeah yeah I
probably wouldn't have gone but you know
would be a nice gesture yeah
hey you want to come I don't want to go
to no regional waters dude I wanna get
well with you but I haven't been see
raising water since high school a few
months ago the Universal Studios we're
going tomorrow okay with my niece what
tunnel she's gonna freak out look they
don't close till 2:00 a.m. well I want
to go to certain it only takes I think
if you do the Fastpass you can get done
with all the mazes in two hours so even
if you go at like 11:30 tomorrow is
actually Hollywood night right yeah
Halloween night yeah yeah yeah we should
go let's all go that'd be amazing
will you go or not my sister says that
kashira T went the mazes are so freakin
good she says the poltergeist stranger
things is really good yeah you know what
notch is a little not up to par it was
great no the actors no but my sister
says it's the same in Universal they
come this close she says I don't want to
check out Universal no no it was good it
was good but it's good that he went into
your face like that that's a bit scared
you you can schedule enough to do a
[ __ ] old-school Chinese pom pom pom
thing yeah is that what you would do in
a real fight is what I'm not concerning
you'll do a palm strike No
just like that or like that his face was
but then is he taller or shorter
well I have a question so who could that
guy sue if he was they come so close
that ya can't believe that no one has
gotten struck before yeah they must sign
a waiver or something yeah yeah no cuz
the reason why he threatened me is
because he had self centered fear so
when people do that like there's you
know like hey man there's cameras in
here it's he's really saying I'm scared
that you're gonna press charges you know
what I'm sayin yeah what wait wait wait
it how could you he pressed roses on you
he didn't touch you no he was afraid
that Steve would press charges what but
yeah but why he has no what do you mean
no no cuz he's afraid that Steve's gonna
press charges on him yeah oh no but he's
doing his job getting in your face
that's what it is right I think you act
him physically yeah but when he when
he's this close you know yeah I know
it's it's like this know that I don't
agree with that because it's like if I'm
doing stand-up right and I insult
somebody right and I called him a con or
whatever right and then trying to sue me
for doing my job he's doing his job
there's only one way to look at it yeah
look at me right now yeah his eyes
closing there's one way to look at it
yeah and you assaulted a guy for doing
his job he will edit this part we're not
why I don't know imagine it happens so
many times you know we should just where
we are how we doing on time we're only
five minutes in okay really five minutes
that we're not even close to being weird
you guys were younger didn't you you
your mom and Steve get stuck in a maze I
don't know if he remembers but Oh
mom took us to a heart like a haunted
house back in the 70s in Minnesota yeah
in Minnesota Minnesota and we were stuck
in there for like five hours yeah she
was screaming I remember her screaming
the finest running yeah we was so pitch
black back in the 70s there was no like
rule lines right there are no lines
sighs just remember in the dark just
going to each room and mom go we gotta
go you know and we were crying screaming
and we're in a surf running in circles I
remember we never got out of there yeah
remember that yeah I remember that at
all
yeah I totally remember that yeah well
you were probably yeah a garden or
something well you were in kindergarten
yeah yeah yeah why is your eyes
squinting right now I don't know I'm
thinking about the the not scary fine do
you feel guilty a little bit do you
think that he's gonna press charges
dampen dampen the mood of the group
laughs because I would have laughed if
you know no no no it well we we got back
to happy the happy fun vibe but it took
a couple other mazes in a roller coaster
ride
[Music]